so the most important question up front
uh so what's your character's name
uh-huh not giving it
I'm getting really good at it now um I
am a Jedi Knight I can tell you that
sure I got some really cool hair let me
tell you that sure so one of the things
the food not this hair it's better than
this true uh what what actually for I
like learning about the behind the
scenes what has surprised you about the
making of this series that you didn't
actually expect uh what goes into the
creatures that like the entirety of I
mean literally sometimes six people
working around on making a living being
um seeing their faces actually move
their eyes blink and I'm not talking
about actors you know what I mean
painted up to be a creature I'm talking
about the builds that they make
um that has been unbelievably cool
unbelievably cool to see them up close
the wrinkles the hair let's talk about
these creatures and what creatures
specific are we talking about
I can't say
um
Jonas uh he plays because they gave that
one away right right so he's playing a
Wookie a Wookie Jedi Master a Wookie
Jedi Master yeah I'm so sorry we need to
get the full yeah the full title in
there yeah Wookie Jedi Master
yeah yeah so that's all I can say
uh what actually
um what has surprised you about the
writing or what do you want to tease
fans about the writing and why they
should be excited for the series look
Leslie's an incredible writer first and
foremost and the entire team
um she's a playwright so she is invested
in story I think what's most exciting to
me and exciting to me to work on this is
that through the language through the
development of these characters you
realize that's bad and good is kind of
at the eyes of the beholder
um
you know things are so multi-layered and
complicated and it takes a really
talented person to write a person that
you can see from all of those angles
well one of the things about the time
period is that the Jedi are sort of
unchecked with their power yeah because
they are the power it's a comment on
policing honestly in my mind which is
why I'm so exciting
um we're at a point where we're at our
highest and you know power is
power can be a difficult thing right
which is you know hypothetically stiff
yes you know hypothetically
hypothetically I'm not saying anything
right hypothetically listen
aim at me for a second hypothetically
hypothetically yes listen I'm gonna let
you go and just say congrats I cannot
wait to see the series okay really and
the footage looked incredible thank you
really thank you thank you